ihr foto shoppen heute youtuber
beziehungsweise nicht ganz foto shoppen
aber ich habe schon mal pad und ich
werde die versuchung nach zu malen
deswegen würde ich auch sagen haben wir
direkt mit meiner lieblings youtube in
an babys beauty palace liebe freunde
die ist hier auf dieser ebene dh diese
ebene werde ich nun auf 50% deckkraft
runterregeln und auf der unteren ebene
hier werde ich nun mit diesem set
versuchen sie nach zu malen also erst
mal jene schöne kontur um die babys
beauty pellet hier rum fragt euch
übrigens nicht was das für ein komischer
bauches den etat hat das war irgendwie
irre 70.000 schwangerschaftswoche und
das musste sie natürlich zelebrieren
nein leute überhaupt nichts gegen baby
also ich finde wirklich den content
denen die in letzter zeit macht da kann
man nicht viel gegen sagen es ist
einfach schön zu sehen wie die jetzt
umgezogen sind in ihre villa wie die
jetzt da sich mit dem kind dann
auseinandersetzen werden ich bin halt
wirklich einfach nur gespannt ob dieses
kind dann auch direkt eine instagram
seite bekommt und so weiter und so fort
oder ob das kind wirklich erfolg aus der
öffentlichkeit herausgehalten wird das
wird sich allerdings zeigen die kontur
haben wir diese idee nicht ganz sauber
aus aber das ist nicht schlimm das heißt
jetzt müssen wir hier die haarfarbe von
der bi so ein bisschen treffen ich
glaube das könnte in etwa hinkommen
gehen wir mal ein bisschen
das ist ein
jetzt ist die maiskolben machen wir das
ganze immer so genau gehen wir hier
einfach so ein bisschen rum wie gesagt
leute wir sind überhaupt nicht die teil
verliert heute
es geht einfach nur darum dass wir
schnell voran kommen denn babys youtube
alles ist natürlich nicht das einzige
foto model was sich in nachbauen werde
sondern ihr müsst auf jeden fall dran
bleiben es werden noch einige andere
youtuber hier gezeichnet da die zähne
schönweiß hier die haben wir nun auch
dann müssen wir nur noch hier erobert
herren warum springt man sein bauch aber
gut machen wir das hier natürlich auch
noch hier der bauchnabel auch noch so
ein bisschen nehmen wir jetzt als
nächste farbe hier natürlich wieder zum
glas ping was sie hier auf diesen fangen
von ihrem bauch hat hier natürlich noch
ihr oberteil beziehungsweise wie jule
sagen würde ihr
ballett
es ist glaube ich dass hier auch noch
komplett ausfüllen und sonst würde ich
sagen haben wir das jetzt auch das heißt
die obere ebene packe ich wieder auf 100
prozent so sieht das noch mal meine
fresse ich bin alle gestiegen ich
brauche nasenspray so sieht das
ursprüngliche bild von instagram von
babys beauty palace aus er meine
gezeichnete version zeige ich euch schon
mal ich habe es noch nicht gesehen
s
das komplett scheiße hab dich gezeichnet
er babys beauty bitte retweet soll das
twittern weiß erstmal ich würde sagen
während meine community darauf jetzt mal
reagiert machen wir hier unser zweites
kunstwerk ich habe ich mir gedacht
kunstwerk ist der richtige name für
erstmal hier natürlich wieder die kontur
so ein bisschen rum zeichnen hier vorne
so
ich hasse das x pert manchmal rutscht
der stift einfach ab und dann zeichnet
der linie einfach weiter ins unendliche
quasi aber so genau also ich weiß
wirklich nicht was ich dafür haare hatte
zu dem zeitpunkt das gesicht und dann
noch hier die lippen und dann haben wir
noch die nase also wie gesagt freunde
wir geben überhaupt keinen bisschen
detaillierter soll ich schon sein ich
will hier überhaupt nicht richtig ins
detail gehen weil wir wirklich ich habe
insgesamt sieben bilder von youtube an
rausgesucht die ich heute bearbeiten
wollte habe ich jetzt natürlich keine
zeit bei jedem einzelnen hier groß wert
auf ihr die nasenlöcher zu geben oder
was weiß ich das blöde ist jetzt nur
dass ich über die konturen drüber
zeichne das hätte ich mir vielleicht
vorher überlegen sollen ich hab grüne
augen das heißt da gehen wir auch so ein
bisschen in die richtung genommen haben
wir hier so ein bisschen und gerührt so
einmal die haare hier auch fertig das
heißt eigentlich ich muss auch die
lippen machen denkt sich für ihn da wird
auch jede woche neu beim arzt also meine
damen und herren mein foto sieht
normalerweise so aus von instagram hat
days geschossen guter kollege von mir
finde ich sehr sehr nice das foto eer
meine bearbeitung davon
scheiße bin ich auf jeden fall trotzdem
mega heiß geworden contractor schreiben
doch gern mal die kommentare was du vor
dem foto hältst dass sie jetzt das
nächste foto meine damen und herren
logan paul da werde ich allerdings jetzt
gar nicht mal so krass auf die farben
eingehen beziehungsweise eigentlich er
gar nicht sondern da geht es mir nur um
die kontur also nur um zu sehen dass ich
ihn hier irgendwie vernünftig darstelle
das ist ja so ein bisschen die challenge
an diesem format hier dass ich versuche
natürlich das ganze so detailgetreu wie
möglich darzustellen allerdings
natürlich auch so schnell wie möglich
denn leute wir haben noch einige 44
weitere bilder vor uns die ich hier
heute foto shoppen möchte bzw
die leute die ich nach malen möchte das
heißt ich hätte natürlich ein timer
stellen können das hätte ich aber das
treffen oder druck es hätte mich dann an
die uni ich mache das einfach dass ich
mir den kopf ich versuche so schnell wie
möglich nachzuzeichnen die mit den
ganzen linie der hat schon krass muskel
aber schon sagen
ja da kann ich tatsächlich nicht
mithalten so wie das originale bild von
logan polen von instagram aus meine
zeichnung sieht
das sieht aus wie sonnen
die sonnen fisch der eine backpfeife
eine backpfeife geben will mit seiner
einzigen vorhandenen flosse noch ich
habe jetzt mal gerade noch den baumstamm
dazu gemalt
sid
siegen raketenwerfer einfach auf den
schultern tragen ich bin halt nicht
picasso apropos picasso wir könnten uns
allerdings einfach mal anschauen was
eventuell einige leute unter unseren
speed an bibi geantwortet haben du
künstler du herren ich weiß dankeschön
hier wird einfach nur geklatscht mega
meinst du künstler warum bist du nicht
künstler und dankeschön was hat er immer
mit baby hey das ist einfach meine
lieblings youtube darf oder will support
und malen es ist halt ein verrat und das
machen große fans als nächstes haben wir
hier julien beim der macht es uns
natürlich hier nicht einfach weil er
seine hand mit im bild hat das kann man
dann immer nicht so gut erkennen wenn
man das nach zeit ich meine ich als
glorreicher künstler kann das aufgrund
meiner erfahrung einfach sagen das ist
hier nicht so easy aber er zeigt schon
hier einen daumen hoch
das heißt leute wenn ihr wollt dass ich
öfter youtuber nach malle dann lasst
auch einen daumen hoch da wollte
eventuell auch mal dass ich nicht die
youtuber nach malle sondern ihr wird ich
habe die ganze zeit hier im auge
jetzt
da ist in 22 wimpern die ich die ich
hier habe
wenn wir zweimal gewünscht das baby mein
bild sieht falls immer wollte dass ich
nicht nur youtube nach malle sondern
eventuell auch mal nach photoshop
berichte ich also richtig hier mal
julien ball an den kopf
die pellets auf ein schädel setzt oder
irgendwie so dann lass mal doppelt like
da dann mache ich das
sorry das nicht so viel in die kamera
guckt hab ich muss ich mein kunstwerk
machen das ist wirklich ein sehr
interessantes bild weil ich mir hierbei
tatsächlich gerade am meisten mühe
gegeben habe im vergleich zu den anderen
bildern die ich heute gemacht habe was
hat denn der für eine augenfarbe machen
wir manchmal auch einfach mal orange ich
bin halt überhaupt keinen mützenträger
ich kann das überhaupt nicht verstehen
ich weiß nicht hier gerne mützen ist
eher geschmackssache habe ich trag
allgemeinen ungern kopfbedeckung auch
bei krebs bin ich mir ganz ganz ganz
ganz unsicher ob die überhaupt stehen
lippen julien gebe ich mir jetzt nicht
so viel mühe mache ich einfach so würde
ich sagen tatsächlich das originalbild
sieht so aus schömberg ich habe dich so
gezeichnet
wir machen weiter mit tyler black angel
händler machen wir natürlich hier vorne
erst mal die kontur bevor ich die kontur
allerdings von ende muss ihrem leben
zeigen ich habe das mit das mit julien
habe ich auch gepostet also wir warten
mal ab was da von der resonanz auf uns
zukommt hier schön das hemd rom genau
hier an der seite dann nehmen wir hier
noch die fingerchen mit genau da müssen
wir uns jetzt auch nicht mehr abgeben
ich habe farben bisher gar nicht drin
the game den rest will ich sagen lassen
was so freunde das heißt das originale
bild hier von ninja sah so aus so hat er
das auf instagram hat er das oder ich
hoffe die pda war das oder so meine
nachzeichnen davon sieht so aus
ist
ist nicht ist nicht so gut geworden
kylie jenner möchte die oder hasst die
ich finde es auch bedenklich bin ich
ganz ehrlich dass sie jede hier sich
alles hat irgendwie machen lassen
irgendwie brüste und po und nase und
keine ahnung was das find ich ja schon
immer sehr krass wenn sich leute alles
vergrößern das natürlich klar wenn man
mit seinem körper nicht zufrieden ist
und es ist ja jedem selbst überlassen
was ich will jetzt niemanden hätten der
irgendwie was in seinem körper fördert
oder so allerdings ist es ja schon krass
wenn man vor allem bedenkt dass sie halt
früher so aussah das ist halt das halt
schon krass jetzt sieht sie so aus ist
sie so das schönheitsideal schlechthin
für alle frauen teilen ich bin ganz
ehrlich suchseiten ab woche jetzt
gefühlt gerade den richtigen farbton für
dein kleidchen hier vorne aber ich werde
das jetzt einfach so machen dafür muss
man eben eine neue ebene machen genauso
das passt das in etwa ich habe keinen
bock ihr die ganzen pailletten und die
haben manchen dann auch noch darauf
zumal in lipstick keine ahnung ob das
jetzt irgendwie der richtige kylie
jenner neue krams hier auf dem markt ist
weiß ich es mir auch komplett scheißegal
kai die wende da siehst kannst mir am
arsch vorbei gehen soll damit das mal
gesagt dass also das hier ist das
ursprüngliche bild meine version von
kylie jenner so finde ich das schöner
als das bin ich ganz ehrlich kommen wir
nun allerdings zur letzten personen die
ich malen wollte
da haben wir sehr viele leute gesagt
helfen können könnte ja auch mal wieder
drauf reagieren
die bank kann bzw einer von denen ich
weiß nicht genau wer das jetzt gerade
ist weil ich da auch nicht so krass im
bilde bin bin ich ganz ehrlich machen
dir das ganze jetzt mal zu einer
gewissen challenge ihr ich muss jetzt
versuchen den hier nachzuzeichnen
allerdings nur mit einer linie damit ich
mich die ganze zeit hier schon dabei
hier die nase lang genau jetzt muss ich
irgendwie zurück noch das auge hier
mitnehmen ich bin immer noch bei einer
linie das kann ich euch auch gleich
beweisen dadurch dass ich einfach mal
rückgängig mache das ganze gehen heute
wieder zurückgeben können doch jetzt
einfach linien langen das mantra zu
aufgefallen das heißt sollte wenn ich
wirklich einen schritt zurück wie ihr
seht das ist alles eine linie mit der
ich das gezeichnet habe das hier ist das
originale bild was von big hit auf
instagram hochgeladen wurden meine eine
linie colin dings von den bankern boys
von einem von der bank dann wo es sieht
so aus
alter meinen don't often allerdings
schauen wir mal was die leute unter das
bild von julian berger auf twitter
geschrieben haben kannst du mal wieder
ein video machen wo du das machst hey
lutz maerker mache ich ja gerade mega
nice to superkünstler dankeschön schwul
dummer hund
ok danke kevin alpha 123 echt geil
hässlich bin picasso wunderschön omg wie
schön die findet so
ist sie wenn ich sowas sehe dann mein
markt ist grade runter
an der stelle mich dass heute die
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren ich bin halt der allerbeste
künstler
das wollte ich halt mit diesem video
noch unter beweis stellen ich denke das
wissen wir alle
wenn ihr wollt ist jetzt ganz normal
mache lasten daumen hoch da wollte
eventuell dass ich die schon gesagt
einfach youtuber wirklich mal photoshop
also und ein gesicht von einer person
auf den kopf von person b dann schreibt
sie ein kommentare und jetzt bin besuche
ich einmal kurz
[Musik]